and I will be historically correct I
cannot wait to read your article in 37
years and say see this is what I said
you got your perspective yeah hey it's
Gary Vaynerchuk how are you I'm good how
are you very good thank you thanks for
the interest so I know how much you've
been apprised the Victorian working on
it I have ache I have a good sense I
also weirdly without knowing the timing
where we got together got into a little
bit of a Twitter conversation last night
so I'm very I'm aware of what we're
talking about and um I've been paying
attention very closely for a very long
time oh great so yeah that was kind of
funny timing with that too you know if
you were given the Mike Trout came into
your office and said you know I want you
to make me a household name I want you
to make me Twitter famous what would you
I would start with a series of questions
for about it 15 to 20 minutes because
you have to reverse engineer someone
who's actually busy and famous you have
to reverse engineer their DNA so for
example Mike could have those ambitions
yet may feel uncomfortable in being out
there because he may think it's bragging
because that's just as DNA and I would
explain fine maybe the format that we
need to put you in is a podcast where
you feel more comfortable because you're
shooting the [ __ ] with friends and
that's how we're gonna be able to create
content
some people are super comfortable
running around earth taking selfies and
that's where they create content other
people look look at myself I'm busy I'm
running an actual company that's big I
don't even though I have a huge audience
and and made myself quote-unquote big
by having somebody fill me at all times
to create content to be distributed so
the first thing that has to happen is
there's a very big DNA trait difference
in all these people I would try to
figure out how to create content in a
world where he was comfortable in doing
that because most people feel like they
don't have the time or ironically even
though they're in the public I don't
like it for many different reasons
skeletons in the closet not their DNA
trait they were taught to be humbled by
their grandpa like there's a million
reasons why but it would I would ask him
a series of questions that put me in a
situation that allowed me to create
content out of an om preferably in video
form which would then feed written an
audio form in the way that I think about
it if you could you know sort of walk me
through what personality traits align
with with what format I think the more
extroverted you are the more video
vlogging or having actually somebody
follow you around with a camera which
takes a lot of a lot of internal
understanding to be okay with that
because they could come across you know
like being a charlatan or you know you
know it's a real personality trait which
I have a lot of empathy you know when I
started doing that three years ago I
knew that it was gonna be like frowned
upon but now it's happening at scale on
YouTube in its most basic form extrovert
video and pictures introvert it's being
recorded behind the scenes manifesting
as audio and written how much you work
with with particular individuals and how
much do you work with brand so we work
more with brands at vaynermedia and I do
but with individuals and we have a
division called Vayner Talent where we
have 1213 clients that we do this with
and and then as a human being I'm
spending quite a bit of time with
awfully famous individuals off the
record in giving them my points of view
on how they could do better on social as
how they say
but it's far more holistic than that
it's being a media entity we're working
with brands is their type of brand that
you see perhaps aligning with Mike Trout
you know and and his characteristics as
an athlete or a person you know whether
it's performance-based because he's a
super athlete or back to the point of it
he's so not out there or super
extroverted I'm sure law firms and banks
and insurance companies and you know
professional service companies would
love to have a clean faced clean record
super athlete you know nice boy be the
face of their brand especially the sport
like baseball where you know there's not
as much focus on the individual as there
is in the NBA where you have someone
whose personality is not obviously
outside it's a heavier lift has that
been curling your experience I think
that that is why I think you just walked
into the much much much bigger problem
at hand for baseball I don't believe
that that is a product of anything other
than the way Major League Baseball has
handled themselves versus the NBA
I mean Reggie Jackson had a candy bar in
1977 let's not get confused what's
happening here what's happening here is
that Major League Baseball a decade ago
decided to make short-term economics by
creating BAM their media group so that
they can control all the short-term
dollars at the detriment of being
everywhere where people are and building
up their individuals they've they've
suffocated the creativity in a digital
environment over the last decade there's
plenty of personalities in baseball the
the way that the teams have to do their
creative in social media and the way
that you can't find any baseball content
on the internet unless Major League
Baseball is making a piece of that
action through their accounts has
created a coach
of suppression of of personal brands I
mean literally to the point of a fan of
kolten Wong creating content on
Instagram potentially is gonna be taken
down by Major League Baseball yes
Steph Curry was built not only by Steph
Curry and by the NBA Steph Curry was
built by the fans creating content of
Steph Curry in the trenches where
attention actually is there was plenty
of interest in Derek Jeter and a-rod in
real life Bryce Harper is loaded with
everything that you'd be interested in
it's suppressed out of him
systematically so if you were
Commissioner for a day what would you
change about the league's approach to
digital I would open up the communistic
point of view dramatically and have far
more partnerships and leeway with them
with the actual audience and I would
disproportionately be petrified that six
to thirteen year olds in America
consider Messi Ronaldo
LeBron curry and ninja the Fortnight
player way more famous than any single
baseball player on earth that is going
to play itself out in an extremely
negative way in a 40 year window and
like every other business on earth
baseball decided to treat digital for
short-term money instead of long-term IP
and success and brand I mean the thing
is like I think about baseball fandom as
oh it gets passed down you know
forefathers the sons and you root for
know you know a particular team is
different and if that gift a generation
or if that is skipping a generation you
know is that salvageable it's not
they're gonna take the short term
they're gonna take the short it's funny
how I think about short term I was
literally about to say they take the
short term loss which is actually a
30-year window it's salvageable if they
start now with you know fathers and sons
mothers and daughters interested in
baseball having the ability to pass it
on in
YouTube snapchat app you know how they
were baseball said you're gonna consume
us the way we baseball want not the way
you want and the problem for them is it
was great for the short term you know
and it looked great like they're making
all this money but what they did was
fundamentally destroyed the 50 year
window of their sport in a real way
people are unbelievably naive how this
is gonna play out
it's an incredible sport to take the
family out for the day that's nice
so is soccer during the same time of
year like this is not gonna work out for
baseball on a 50 year window and it
starts with do you care and and I think
that the answer is no I do not believe
so I couldn't be more down on baseball
35 years from now based on what they're
doing now kids are not growing up with
baseball cards like they did there are
tensions in different places there's new
alternatives like everyone's like well
it's a great summer night well guess
what you know what every eight to
thirteen year old in America is doing on
summer nights right now they're staying
inside and playing for night yeah so I
don't care that you're good for the
outside if nobody's going outside you're
finished and guess what I think people
need a history lesson boxing and horse
racing were the most popular sports
along with baseball in this country in
nineteen twenty thirty and forty and
they were radio sports that's why and
then television came along and football
and basketball were television sports
and guess what they benefited and guess
what now we're in a digital world and
that's who's gonna benefit a ke sports a
ke things like the NBA that understand
how to manipulate it and it was gonna
lose baseball you know why because they
make an extra hundred million dollars in
little pennies and nickels in ads on
their channels that they Rev share with
YouTube or Facebook yet nobody's going
there and it's not cultural and nobody
gives a crap
and then classic NHL that's always been
bad decides to sign up with BAM I mean
talk about a sport that's barely holding
on to relevance and so what they did
what they did was literally go into the
same drug and sign up with BAM media
which is devastating to me
hawky super hard to get excited about
something if you can't see it and I
don't want to hear like well players
have accounts on social they sure do
but when the team's content is sucked
into being controlled by the
organization like it doesn't fester a
culture the Padres don't have a culture
of creating content that's really
progressive because it's part of the BAM
machine so they're sucking off the teeth
of BAM and there's and so then all of a
sudden if there's not a culture inside
the organization well the players don't
feel a natural kinship towards that
right and it's crazy because baseball
super culture Matt Kemp dated Rihanna
like they have nothing but ammo
culturally you know what I mean no and I
think I mean they certainly succeeded
and I mean maybe there's some pushback
but I do think baseball has succeeded in
making it seem like the players problem
as opposed to the league problem so to
me that's a really great great
conversation because any time a leader
says their employees are at fault there
in the beginning of the process of the
end ya know the utter lack of
accountability is laughable baseball
took the money in the short term in
digital and they destroyed it the long
term value of the entire thing because
of it the end and I will be historically
correct I cannot wait to read your
article in 37 years and say see this is
what I said do you think though even in
that climate there's a way for players
yes yes of course I do but it is so much
more in the best interest of the teams
than it is for the players the players
are there for three to twelve years the
teams are trying to do it in perpetuity
but what you had was a bunch of old
owners take the cash because when we
write when you're owned by 32 people
that are of the ages of 59 as the
youngster 292 you take the short term
economics please understand my energy
I'm angry at the owners for
not holding up a sanction of baseball
for the long-term for their selfish
short-term financial wants so yes do I
think Aaron judge could do anything and
everything of course I do but I do think
maybe because I am a CEO and like being
a leader that you need to create the
environment for people to flourish and I
believe baseball has done that digitally
contemporarily or you know the end and
whatwhat's baseball doing about it what
I'm doing with all the what where is all
that money going Erin judge makes a lot
of money a lot a lot and he can hire a
social media person cool the Dodgers
make a lot of money where's it going
yeah like where is it going
and so the utter lack of investment in
the long term IP of the asset you own
only speaks to my confidence in my
bravado on this subject matter and by
the way here's the point of this
there'll be plenty of people that read
this or watch this that are gonna
disagree with me because you don't see
it happening until it's too late
right people gonna tweet at me and be
like Gary you're an idiot attendance is
up okay guess what most companies that
go out of business
have their best year before the
beginning of the end
toys are up when I was saying toys Rus
was out of business people [ __ ] on me
left and right because they pointed to
the numbers of the sales I was like
that's cute but you don't understand
that they're not positioned for the
future let's look real life if you're an
86 year old owner and you and if you're
even smart enough to realize what's
happening and you're saying but yeah but
I'm making so much more economics on the
digital rights and my kids aren't gonna
be left with this anyway because of the
way tax his work and inheritance tax and
so I'm gonna leave this bag on the next
um dope that's really what's happening
the 80 year old owner is saying I don't
give a [ __ ] about the Angels I care
about me and and I care about my kids
but I'm not gonna leave it to them
anyway because they can't pay the
inheritance tax so they're gonna sell it
right
yeah and I just don't care about
baseball in 2063
I genuinely believe that's what's
happening with them and listen carefully
with the most intelligent of owners the
dopes the owners don't even realize it's
happening because they so disrespect
where the attention of the consumer
actually is why didn't wrestling get big
in the 80s because Vince McMahon knew
where the kids attention was and if you
put wrestling on Saturday morning and if
you put wrestling on MTV then people
care all that the Internet is now
Instagram Facebook snapchat YouTube
podcasts that is MTV I think there are a
lot of baseball writers who whose retort
is sort of along the line well you if
you can't appreciate what's so great
about Mike Trout then hell with you
anyway that's great that's what
everybody says before they go out of
business right right if you don't love
my product well then you're an idiot
cool the market is always right I I'm a
Sevilla preach I'm you know big of a
boxing fan I am like it's called the
sweet science it is one of the most
fascinating things for me to watch right
here's the product when it all went
pay-per-view and nobody could see it on
free TV everybody lost the appreciation
cuz they didn't see it there's a very
specific reason
soccer's happened in America more that's
ever had before
it's called FIFA the video game and it's
called English Premier League games are
actually on television in the morning on
Saturday yeah it's this is not
complicated this is what I do for a
living
it's called attention and Major League
Baseball has absolutely dropped the ball
over the last decade on attention and
they will feel the ramifications over
the next half century but I think but I
think but I think to your point I think
you can sense it it's super important
because it's not about Mike Trout
because then you can absolutely make
this a very narrow argument about one
man's personality this is yeah this is
epidemic this is how do we get to this
moment because I'm sure you agree with
me that you know there are tons of guys
in the
that have nothing I mean do you know
much money I could make Aaron Jett judge
just on the gap in between his two front
teeth from a business standpoint I just
think you need to make that you know you
need to make that culture Jose Altuve is
five foot five like everything that
everybody says - why you know why Steph
Curry is so culturally amazing because
everybody feels they can be him
Hosea today is a Latino who's five foot
five that is unbelievably at scale in
America right yeah I mean these are
these are ridiculous conversations you
know Matt Kemp dekes models like there's
plenty of things to be done how many r
bias has more personality in his left
pinky than most athletes in America
right right I mean that has even gotten
into the fact that 38% of these dudes
are strikingly handsome and if you just
take their shirt off and put it on
Instagram
lots of good [ __ ] will happen the thing
is like and it did cross my mind when I
was when I was conceiving of this story
because they said well okay so traps not
famous but then really like if you look
around the game maybe Harper and and
Justin Verlander 50 days they made up
dinner I get married Upton are famous
but I don't really know you know David
Ortiz was famous he's retired yeah hard
to see yeah and meanwhile you've got you
you've got so much look when we're we're
having a marketing discussion not an on
a feel discussion right one of the best
baseball players in the world plays in
Boston and his name is Mookie yeah like
like like you know like there's so much
scooter gannett is scooter nice nice guy
in a nice market there's so much to do
with him I mean look I really know
baseball like this is not I'm not
pontificating from now I know if you
know that you know big
I drafted scooter Gennett two years ago
when he got cut by the Brewers because I
knew how good of a prospect he was like
I really know baseball like I really
know baseball I'm not even talking about
culturally but like you get me Manny
Machado forget about getting traded to
the Dodgers and now he's in LA
you give them him in Baltimore I'll make
him a real celebrity I've made myself a
bigger celebrity than these guys I'm a
42 year old business man let's talk
about another thing back to you know
whether it's Segura or whether it's you
know Baez or or or Altuve or Eddie
Rosario who's exploding another guy
drafted three years ago by the way for a
dollar in my fantasy league I mean
America has never been more Latin has
never been more Latino Hispanic has
never been more especially at the youth
and baseball is the most Hispanic Latino
in our country this is a they're not
putting out content where people
actually live and that's it's as simple
as that
they don't have a culture of it they
they took the short game and they will
pay the price can I throw another thing
on you because I think it adds to the
Mike Trout conversation because it
because it uses Bryce Harper who I think
is always the fun kind of right that's
the fun conversation with those two
right I mean would you not agree with
this I believe baseball as a platform
has sucked the star power and charisma
out of Bryce Harper that he naturally
came in with I blame explain more sure
let's think about Bryce Harper's
personality six or seven years ago I
think people are going to talk about
well he grew up and that's why he's not
acting as you know yeah yeah right I say
not true I say he's been suppressed by
the culture of I think I think that's
possible although again that's something
where you don't know whether that's
coming from the leaves or from the
clubhouse I I could I come on I couldn't
I couldn't agree more
you could have a 41 year old catcher
that puts a hand on the kid and says yo
kid shut the [ __ ] up right I'm a funny
you know an actor I have a funny feeling
if Major League Baseball had a culture
where a 41 year old catcher could make
$300,000 off the field because he's a
personality that you would see things
change
systematically yeah and so I'm with you
I think I as you can tell I'm not naive
to this this is something I'm very
passionate about and know a lot of the
nuances I'm speaking to its Major League
Baseball as the organization's
requirement to create a culture of Fame
and fun and contemporary executions that
would then over time trickle down to
it's so funny because I I was at the
game yesterday in an elevator with Rob
Manfred I wish I did this I mean look
listen I've unbelievable amounts of
respect for the point of view I just
unbelievably disagree and right and he
is the employee of owners so he runs the
company line but yeah it is very clear
that they took the short money and ran
with it and they will be the generation
that made baseball culturally irrelevant
well and this is a little bit perhaps
relevant you know I I remember I an old
boss of mine used to kind of make the
argument that the the whole steroid saga
was thought to mistakes because it
resulted in the commissioner and
ownership demonizing the biggest stars
of the game and and making them into
pariahs
and consequently maybe you see you know
baseball in the two examples that you
just said and it's an interesting
thought I haven't spent a lot of time
thinking about it so as you can see I'm
passionate when I've thought a lot and I
get a little more quiet but if let's say
we agreed after and I'm gonna let that
marinate for a month and I'll text you
and be like you were right I let's say
we agree you know what that speaks to
another example when baseball's not
taking on its responsibility and
throwing it on the player yesterday it's
the players fault that he's not more
famous
I need him to tango with me are you
kidding me with the steroid here you're
absolutely right actually it didn't take
me very long to marinate they threw
their players under they threw their
players under the bus
I want one common sense individual to
sit down with me and tell me they didn't
know what was going on right here's my
here's my problem
parents love to [ __ ] on Millennials
without recognizing they're the ones who
created them yeah the utter lack of
accountability against their own stars
is devastating to me
baseball is very good at not taking on
accountability it's time it does and
they better move quickly because very
quickly people are gonna be watching
video game players throw swords at each
other instead of baseballs and hitting
with bats very quick there it's already
happened
now it's can they start the process of
unwinding it because the data yeah the
days of baseball cards in your bike
spokes are over yeah no I mean it's
absolutely true and it's just like if
they can't make if they can't make a
generation of young players if they are
talented the silver to think that it's
over yeah it's over and and and you know
what for that you know the audacity to
make Mike Trout the part of the
conversation when he's everything you'd
ever want right right
like my great goal in life is Mike Trout
is the kind of guy my daughter marries
so the fact that they're willing to go
like is have we gotten to that place
where we're now
that's who they're willing to subtly
throw under the bus because don't get it
twisted that's exactly what he did
yesterday ya know and like I mean I'm
just thinking now you know I if you've
ever spent any time around life
Francisco Lindor or something and you
know I probably talked to the guys 15
minutes total in my life but how is that
guy not you know preaching your
preaching and guess what it's a
Baseball's job when [ __ ] LeBrons
there during their World Series run to
get LeBron with Lindor in a pacer and
all over social media
I mean juju Smith's Shuster is doing a
better job hacking creature than the
entire major league baseball machine
wait where's the money going they're not
reinvesting in their business they're
sucking it dry and they will pay the
price period and the story period end of
story
every other conversation is the micro
and is fundamentally irrelevant to the
actual thing that's happening yeah cool
I gotta go yeah this is awesome man
Thank You Man take care all right bye
that's a lesson for everybody in
everything in life